welcome to this video playing kiedy from
france and spanish or willow pass what
about the balloon I haven't played this
yet on video we need to win a rare
answer but not too bad can i play 94
here it's probably not great ok let's
just cancel 94 here yeah in general the
exchange of notes something that black
likes to do because it done it helps to
the exchange as a c6 night and this
helps to play c 6 i'm not quite sure
what he's doing here it looks a bit
weird to me just giving me the center
why would you put the knight on c3 not
sure why ok Bishop g4 needs to then he
needs to retreat the the Queen no
problem doesn't hurt to to misplace it a
bit too let's prevent Bishop g5
yeah I can take it right he would take
with the pawn
yeah gameplay default shouldn't this be
a good structure now take here it's not
a good structure a chance flatout
winning material okay this was really
strange playing a 3 just winning the
rook now in the corner or like this
white resigns ok so I'm this was a quick
one yeah f3 it was just a weird move but
it did it looks very strange from from
the get-go hard to tell why you would
would play that if he goes let's say
here but it's probably nothing special
maybe yeah yeah I prefer black slightly
because of the two sent up once but it's
nothin great going on the way you plated
it just it just lost but but think of it
after this check if he goes not to see
one which is really like like a helpmeet
giving away the rook like this it's
still playable I guess
something like this
I don't know some symbols yeah this
looks okay for black but it's not it's
not lost okay thanks for watching good
game